what can I say about ancestry.com my
adventure began when I received a leaf
pointing me in the direction of my
great-grandfather who was a pilot with
the flying aces in World War One on my
mother's side I found an aunt who traced
her lineage all the way back to Thomas
Jefferson
I was able to trace my bloodline back to
Nobles and even a king I discovered I'm
a direct descendant of Eric the Red
after only a couple of hours on
ancestry.com I was able to trace my
family line all the way back to none
other than our third president
Thomas Jefferson Marie Antoinette Thomas
Jefferson
Aristotle Thomas Jefferson Alexander the
Great Thomas Mother Jefferson join
ancestry.com and begin a one-of-a-kind
journey into your unique past because
you never know where your Story begins
[Music]